let's have a look at this guy again
remember how I said to you I'm pushing
on this a little further
I'm not just giving the else purse
panted easy uses of general solution I'm
going to answer a little more
interesting and sort of raised more
questions forms so here's one that
doesn't even look like it's a general
solution problem at all there's
something is one thing that tells you
this has to be a general solution
problem there's something that's there
or should I say there's something that's
not there yeah yeah this is the
restriction on X yeah so it's like look
I made just one would like the first
couple or the first ones over here I'm
what all of them so if you see that note
domain they might be nice to say find
the general solution all but as it
stands at the moment that's the only
solution you can find because you need
all now before we launch into it when we
see this question just on the face of it
you can solve especially in the
restricted domain you already know how
to do this how would you do it if I
didn't if you didn't know anything that
general solution yeah yeah look at this
that's a wave function that's a wave
function sum of two main functions is
I'm on the wave function okay and we
will have a look at that in a second
yes okay you can do some division if
you're willing to exclude some solutions
right and they have to test them back to
it so that's another way we can do this
many ways to kill onions he's only I'm
going to show us I'm going to show you
two ways to do this using what you know
my channel solution here's where I'm
gonna be in which one shall I do first
let's deploy okay
so I'm going to kick this sign term over
to the other side okay that's what I'm
going to do the reason why I have it why
I'm going in this direction is because
I'm trying to get a cause of something
that's causing something else or
alternatively sine of something is sine
of something else if I can get it in
that board I can use these general
Fisher's very nicely in it
since that's the direction of hitting
you now of course the problem at the
moment is I don't have a closet of
colors or sign in the sign there's lots
of ways you can resolve it okay I'm just
going to show you one of it because I
think it's fun
- sign X what does it look like if you
just think about it from the multitude
five you know what regular sine X looks
like so this guy is upside down right so
this is what pads of the general shape
of the U sine X yep
now what I want is to turn that into
some version of person okay now it
should be able to do this because the
relationship between a sine and cosine
is a it's a phase shift to relationship
right if I just move sideways I should
be able to get from version cosine so
the question is which way would you like
me to move and I hope I didn't wait I
think moving to the right or maybe
quickest way right let's just think that
if I take this shape and move in PI or
two to the right
why are they choosing PI over two
because it's the roots inside and it's
complement rightful design so I'm going
to move a plan to radiance to the right
that shapes going to look something like
we're gonna see that that's the part of
it that I got what's the part of missing
it's it's this guy over here look at
that if I move this part is the right
that's exactly the same ground did you
see that
so what am I gonna write here I want
this is cause of something okay so in
the green
I've got regular cosine and in the blue
I've got a version of coastline it's
gone Payan to radiance to the think
think is cosine if I wanted to move
cosine back onto this back which is the
one I want
which way has it gone right cuz we just
start this in Reverse so therefore I can
write this as X I've gone to the left so
it's plus PI on to see that we know how
shifts work there get backwards to the
side
okay so this is kind of sweet because I
can say cause of something call us or
something else that's really really nice
so I'm just going to watch straight into
my general solution what's the general
solution for Siberia to apply plus or
minus whatever closet most of these
things right so that's two n PI plus or
minus in this country yeah okay so when
you have a look at that you came hmm
again I want to do some simplifying here
but I like with info site right sorry
side in general solution you've got two
branches because the switchy theme I've
got two branches here soon so I'm going
to separate them out so I'm gonna go
over here and here
I'll do the negative case first and they
don't do the positive or here's what I
get when I think about the - okay that's
just me taking the right aside and
expanding the brackets what would the
right-hand side look like what happens
when I take the positive side x equals
one
so what helped ya 2i plus X plus y o2
okay now the reason I read them is I've
got both my cases and then I consulted
but before I even put pen to paper I
noticed something a little bit weird
little bit weird
hmm yeah you look at this right hand
side right and you're like oh well
there's noble thing to do is to subtract
X from both sides and then you realize
oh it's problem here so what does this
mean about this branch of the Equator
there's no X you can put in there that
will make that right hand side true so
I'm not going to get any solutions from
that branch of my shoe
plus the transition dr. Kim let's come
over to this guy okay what am I gonna do
this time I'm gonna add these least meet
this leads me to a pie
during my - fine - and then I only have
to do one more thing to get my solution
which is duck